like knockout or turkey
so
great again with lost
with the guessed
well if he still plays knight f3 very early on of
course you have no
problems at least emphasizing the run
well well but you
talk trouble with g4
and now I actually always
expected that springer h4 or springer would
pull 5 each
and get the new building away
now even more dawdling
because I jump four myself
then I no longer have such a problem
with the runner
as the problem means maybe we should
n’t just exchange them
yes that is actually always quite
pleasant
this position with the a-line and then
bvb four as a possibility
as
good as i can't prevent a
media player from taking away
java c4 i had malsfeld in mind anyway
and if he gave me that with chess it
would be nice
yes but i still have the train here
or
your story four just
gone so make it go here again so
that he has to give up the runner
yes e
seems to get him back if i
fulfilled maybe can't play well a
moment f5 seems to despise the knight sound more
but not going okay but it
's also so very pleasant the
position
if he gets it again now
oh I see  right now
is not threatening to take the
wf 54 and catch the bishop then i
can prepare it for you
now yes there is coming my colleague
there might also get a pawn
or knight 25 b 7
so a
piece like me is gone now  yes I
think they
hide everything nicely from each other
but watch the towers connect
yes so well activate and maybe
watch win a pawn
he really can't do anything
adjustment what I covered everything also
mutually
the nice jump on the 15 the bishop
his motto none  chances more yes that
went amazingly fast a job also
several weird closed king d2 and
then and then i ran  hr okay he
just put something away